after two days of protests a spiraling
battle against government plans to curb
civil liberties in Georgia may have been
pulled from the brink the ruling party
announced that it would step back from
draft legislation that protesters said
echoed a civil society Crackdown in
Russia but no one is taking that for
granted we just want to fulfill our
dreams and do we want to finish the job
that we started two days ago of course
it's great news that they want to cancel
but this
order still exists and if it will be
canceled we will be happy Georgian
opposition leaders treated the
government's announcement with Extreme
Caution
the morning Georgian Dream published the
state
they they're ready to cancel the bill
Russian bill that provoked the protest
peaceful protest in the streets releases
streets we do not believe in this
political statement because we have very
sad experience that George and green has
light public Georgian publicity several
times Wednesday night saw violent
confrontations with police using tear
gas water cannon and stun grenades the
protesters insisted the so-called
transparency of foreign funding bill
supported by many MPS on Tuesday would
stifle press Freedom silence descent and
compromise the former Soviet country's
chances of joining NATO and the EU
the bill requires ngos and media Outlets
receiving more than 20 percent of their
funding from abroad to register as
foreign agents for face heavy fines if
around 80 percent of Georgian population
still is very pro-western and they see
their future in West so that's very
important for our government as we see
to demonize these people and to to
damage the reputation of the
organizations of donors of those who
work with them and to isolate Georgia
the draft Bill had the backing of the
governing Georgian Dream party amid
chaotic scenes in Parliament the Prime
Minister Iraqi Gary bashvili said it
would help root out those working
against Georgia's interests interests
that appear to differ from those on the
streets Jonah Al Jazeera